-Qui est pour ?
Qui est contre ?
-La séance est levée.
Générique
...
Musique folklorique
à la guitare
...
-OLE !
-Bonjour, je suis
Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie,
député des Bouches-du-Rhône.
*Nous sommes dans le cadre
des derniers préparatifs
de la Feria d'Istres.
Dans le cadre
de la proposition de loi
visant à interdire
la pratique de la corrida,
j'ai voulu vous emmener
à la rencontre des acteurs
*de cette réalité
économique, sociale,
culturelle et rurale
qui est la nôtre ici.
-Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie
s'est donné une mission :
défendre la tauromachie.
Ce député
Rassemblement National
est l'élu d'une circonscription
où le taureau est roi : la Camargue.
La corrida se pratique
aux arènes d'Arles
et d'Istres.
C'est ici justement qu'il vient
rencontrer les passionnés,
quelques heures
avant que les taureaux
ne soient lâchés.
Sur le sable des arènes,
il est attendu
pour une séance d'initiation.
-Monsieur Galtier.
Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie.
-Bonjour, monsieur le député.
-Alors, qu'est-ce que vous voulez
me faire faire ?
-Venez voir, je vous montre.
On va s'approcher.
Venez par là.
Vous êtes novice,
d'après ce que vous me dites ?
-Je vais aux corridas, mais...
-Les deux instruments
qu'un torero utilise,
il y a d'abord la cape,
et ensuite, la muleta.
-Hm-hm.
-Une cape, ça se tient forcément
à deux mains,
ni trop serré,
parce qu'on n'aura pas d'envergure
pour dévier le taureau,
ni trop large non plus.
Quand je la déploie, elle doit
être présentée comme un bouclier.
Voilà...
-Les pouces à l'intérieur ?
En plus, c'est pas léger.
-Là, c'est pas mal.
-Là ?
-Voilà.
-C'est lourd. Ca pèse un âne mort.
-Là, je fais le taureau,
il est devant vous.
Déviez-moi là-bas.
Voilà, parfait.
Voilà, le taureau, il va faire ça,
et maintenant, là-bas,
toujours là-bas.
-OK.
On y va.
-Non, la cape n'est pas devant vous.
C'est un bouclier, la cape.
-Très bien.
-Voilà,
c'est pas mal.
Il soupire.
-Peut mieux faire !
Est-ce que c'est une légende,
qu'ils sont attirés par le rouge,
ou c'est esthétique ?
-C'est une légende.
Il y en a qui ont toréé
avec des muletas blanches,
ça marche, bleues...
-Oui...
-Le taureau,
il fonce sur ce qui bouge.
-C'est extrêmement technique,
c'est extrêmement esthétique,
quand on peut voir
les gestes des toreros,
et puis...
Ben ça donne envie.
Ca fait envie.
-Guidez, guidez, guidez !
-Mais avant de se lancer
dans une très hypothétique
carrière de torero,
le député a un combat plus urgent
à mener.
Le 24 novembre,
l'Assemblée nationale
doit voter pour ou contre
une proposition de loi
visant à abolir la corrida.
Dans le monde des arènes,
cette échéance est très redoutée.
-On espère vraiment
que cette proposition de loi
ne va pas passer,
pour des raisons économiques,
sociales et culturelles.
-Je vais à la rencontre
de tous mes collègues,
quel que soit
leur groupe politique,
pour leur expliquer
qu'on a tous besoin de leur soutien.
On arrive désormais à une situation
où deux points de vue
- et là je parle poliment -,
mais deux blocs s'opposent :
un bloc, j'allais dire,
de posture intellectuelle,
qui va du wokisme
à une certaine forme de volonté
de détruire tout ce qui fait
notre identité,
et le monde auquel j'appartiens,
qui est concret, réel,
qui ne veut pas
faire de la tradition un fixisme,
mais qui veut qu'elle s'inscrive
dans l'avenir.
C'est ce que je défends.
-La corrida,
un sujet éminemment politique,
et dans la bataille parlementaire
qui s'annonce,
les députés sont très courtisés.
-Nous avons pris le temps
d'appeler les élus,
dans le sud-est,
le sud-ouest,
pour avoir leur avis,
leur faire comprendre l'importance
de la corrida, de la tauromachie,
de la ruralité
sur le territoire.
-Je suis profondément attaché,
en tant que député, plus encore,
en tant que Français,
à ce que nos exceptions culturelles,
qui sont fortement ancrées,
vivent et s'inscrivent
dans l'avenir,
ce en quoi je suis raccord
avec le fil conducteur
de ma famille politique.
-Sa famille politique :
le Rassemblement National,
un parti qui a souvent du mal
à nouer des alliances,
mais quand il s'agit de défendre
la filière taurine,
le député trouve
des oreilles attentives.
Le voici avec François Bernardini,
le maire d'Istres,
président de l'Association
des villes taurines de France
et soutien d'Emmanuel Macron.
-J'ai rencontré
monsieur le député,
on a convenu que nous n'avions pas
des positions communes
régulièrement.
-Non, mais nous avons des valeurs...
-Nous avons effectivement
des visions sur des aspects
qui dépassent ces clivages-là,
et moi, en termes,
tout simplement, de citoyen
qui respecte la démocratie,
je dois travailler
avec tous les gens qui sont portés
à ce type de responsabilités.
Je n'ai pas ni de honte,
ni d'ennui, de le faire.
-A l'heure où la corrida
joue sa survie,
l'union sacrée est donc décrétée
chez ses défenseurs politiques.
...
Le spectacle va commencer.
Le député
rejoint André Viard.
-Comment allez-vous ?
-Ca va, et vous ?
-Merci de votre aide.
-Merci à vous,
surtout.
-Cet ancien torero
est une figure incontournable
du lobby taurin.
Les deux hommes se faufilent
au bord de la piste
pour assister à une novillada :
une corrida où de jeunes toreros
affrontent de jeunes taureaux.
...
Au fur et à mesure
que le combat avance,
des banderilles sont plantées
dans le corps de l'animal,
qui commence à saigner.
-C'est que dalle.
Je disais,
le sang que perd le taureau là,
proportionnellement,
c'est moins
que ce que vous donnez
à la Croix-Rouge pour faire un don.
Les banderilles,
c'est vraiment minime.
Quand on les regarde,
elles font 5 cm,
mais le taureau,
il fait 400 kg, celui-là.
C'est impressionnant
si on n'a pas le courage
de regarder la mort,
la blessure, en face,
mais la notion de souffrance
n'est pas la même
pour l'humain ou le taureau.
-Vient alors le point culminant
d'une corrida : l'estocade.
Le torero grogne d'effort.
Acclamations
La mise à mort
se fait d'un coup d'épée,
placé le plus souvent
entre l'omoplate droite
et la colonne vertébrale.
La mort est rarement instantanée
mais elle intervient rapidement
si le torero
a bien rempli son office.
...
-Le combat
était juste,
le taureau a été valeureux,
le torero a été
tout aussi valeureux, on l'a vu...
Je crois pas qu'on puisse appeler ça
de la torture,
ça me choque pas.
Je crois pas que dans les abattoirs,
les images
soient aussi agréables à voir.
Je crois qu'il faut se garder
de toute forme de sensiblerie
anthropomorphique.
Un taureau sauvage
n'est pas un être humain.
-Cette vision du député
n'est pas partagée
par tous ses confrères.
Pour d'autres élus,
au contraire,
la corrida
est un spectacle insupportable.
A l'Assemblée,
c'est le député France Insoumise
Aymeric Caron
qui porte le fer.
Il est l'auteur
de la proposition de loi
visant à interdire la corrida.
Dans l'exposé des motifs,
il écrit ceci.
Dans son combat,
Aymeric Caron n'est pas seul.
Sur le terrain,
les militants anticorrida
préparent, eux aussi,
la guérilla parlementaire.
Nous sommes à Arles,
dans la circonscription
d'Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie.
Claire Starozinski est la présidente
de l'Alliance anticorrida.
Elle aussi est en ordre de bataille
pour convaincre les députés
de voter pour la loi Caron.
Documents à l'appui,
les militants de son association
vont frapper aux portes
des permanences parlementaires.
-Là, oui,
c'est un vrai lobbying,
parce que chaque personne
va voir son propre député
- les députés
sont quand même élus,
et ce sont
les représentants du peuple -
et va lui dire
ce qu'est exactement la corrida.
Ici, chez nous, dans le sud,
la corrida, on sait ce que c'est,
mais c'est tout.
Dans les autres départements,
passés 100 km au nord,
personne sait ce que c'est.
Les gens nous disent d'ailleurs
toujours :
"Mais y a encore la mise à mort,
en France ?"
La corrida, c'est un taureau
qui est supplicié,
avec à peu près 1,5 mètre
d'armes blanches
qui perforent son corps.
Donc effectivement,
le taureau souffre,
car au même titre que l'humain,
il ressent la douleur.
On ne peut plus accepter
ce genre de cruauté,
de barbarie sur un animal
juste pour le plaisir,
soyons clairs.
-Au-delà des derniers instants
du taureau,
les défenseurs de la corrida
insistent souvent
sur sa vie avant les arènes.
Dans les grands espaces de Camargue,
voici un élevage de toros bravos,
les taureaux braves.
Cette espèce, importée d'Espagne,
est celle qui finit sa vie
face aux toreros.
-C'est un lot de taureaux que j'ai.
On voit que celui sur la gauche,
c'est un petit taureau
qui va faire 3 ans.
Un taureau de corrida,
il va à l'arène à partir de 4 ans.
Donc il passe quand même quatre ans
sur les terres qui l'ont vu naître.
-Sur un élevage extensif.
-Complètement extensif.
Il ne rentre pas à l'étable...
Ils sont sauvages.
-Ils n'ont pas besoin
de l'intervention humaine.
-On n'intervient jamais dessus.
Ils ont une belle vie,
vous vous rendez compte ?
-Je connais pas beaucoup de...
-Je connais pas de bovin
qui vive quatre ans minimum
dans un cadre aussi magnifique.
C'est un animal magnifique,
le taureau.
Ca représente la force,
la virilité.
Pour moi, c'est mon dieu,
le taureau.
-Y a une déification de l'animal,
c'est pas pour rien
qu'on leur érige des statues,
qu'on les honore,
qu'on les respecte...
La corrida participe grandement...
-A ça.
-Oui, à cette quasi-religion
autour de l'animal.
-Sans la corrida,
on n'aurait plus aucune raison
d'élever du taureau de combat.
C'est pas rentable
pour la viande,
parce qu'on met trop de temps
à faire du poids,
et ça nous coûterait
trop cher,
et c'est un animal,
une race,
qui existe pour finir dans l'arène,
pour le combat,
pas pour autre chose.
-Si la corrida disparaît,
l'impact économique sera donc
important dans la circonscription.
-La corrida...
-Si on l'abolit,
nos élevages
disparaîtront :
il n'y aura plus de raison
que ça existe,
on n'aura plus de débouchés
du tout.
Après, ça va être
une perte économique
pour les villes.
A Arles, le maire a annoncé
jusqu'à 12 millions d'euros
de retombées sur deux ferias.
C'est pas rien.
-Ouais, un peu plus à Nîmes.
-Un peu plus à Nîmes,
et y a pas que ces deux villes.
Il y a d'autres petites villes
qui font des ferias.
-Pour les commerces,
ce serait catastrophique
s'il n'y avait plus la feria.
-Tout à fait.
...
-Abolir ou sauver la corrida
en France,
c'est un choix d'abord éthique
mais qui a aussi
des conséquences économiques.
Le 24 novembre, le débat
n'a pas eu lieu à l'Assemblée.
Aymeric Caron a retiré son texte
au dernier moment,
dénonçant un nombre trop important
d'amendements,
rendant impossible son examen.
Sur les 612 amendements déposés,
58 étaient signés
Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...